hey vsauce michael here in 2003
researchers did the measurements and
found
that kansas is in fact
literally flatter than a pancake
of course the earth is not flat the
earth is round
otherwise travelers would be falling off
the edge all the time
right wrong
if the earth was not a ball shape but
was instead
a flat disc like this plate
well with the right density and
thickness living in the middle could
feel pretty normal
but as you moved toward the edge gravity
on a disc earth
would slightly skew pushing at a greater
and greater angle
back toward the center my friend nick
from yeti dynamics put together this
great
simulation the person and buildings
obviously aren't to scale but check out
how such
increasingly diagonal gravity would work
although this is a flat disc it would
feel to a runner headed toward the edge
like they were fighting to climb up a
steeper and steeper hill
the building foundations behind the
runner reflect how you would have to
build structures
closer and closer to the edge so that
people living in them
always felt like down was at right
angles to the floor
the way we feel it on our big round
earth now as you approach the edge
things would get scary remember this is
a
flat earth but it would feel like a
sheer drop off
what's really cool is that contrary to
the don't fall off the edge
fear on a flat world because of gravity
the scary risk would actually be falling
away from the edge and rolling all the
way back to the center
once you stepped over the edge instead
of
falling off into space you'd be able to
relax
it would be a nice level place
this model of course neglects the fact
that such a planet shape
would be impossible anything as massive
as the earth
shaped like a flat disk would under its
own gravity naturally collapse back into
a ball
this is why in outer space everything
more than a few hundred miles in
diameter
is round or so we've been told
what if gravity isn't real what if the
earth
is in fact flat and science has been
wrong all along
it's a misconception that christopher
columbus discovered that the earth
is round virtually every scholar and
major religion in the west
accepted earth's rotundity since at
least the time
of the ancient greeks who for instance
had noticed that boats disappear
bottom first when sailing away and as
you walk north and south
stars pop into and out of view the
misconception
that only a few hundred years ago lots
and lots of people believed the earth
was flat
likely began in the modern era as a sort
of
insult a well your people recently
thought the earth was flat so why should
we believe you now
the smear was repeated and published so
often it became accepted
as historical fact flat earther became
synonymous with anti-science
it might seem flat over short distances
but over longer ones
well the earth is pretty darn curvy the
verrazano narrows bridge connecting
staten island and brooklyn had to be
designed with earth's
roundness in mind its two towers
separated by 1300 meters and perfectly
vertical
are nonetheless 41 millimeters further
apart at the top
than at the bottom because of earth's
curvature
in the 3rd century bc eradisthinis
measured the differences between shadows
cast by poles in
cyen and alexandria to calculate
more than 2 000 years before rockets and
space
travel the circumference of the entire
globular earth with for the time
impressive accuracy
word got around that the earth was
around shape after that but in 1906
wilbur glenn valava became head of a
slightly bizarre religious sect that
pretty much ran the city
of zion illinois valava believed that
the earth was
actually flat and he enforced flat earth
teachings
in schools in zion he also enforced that
belief on
really anyone who entered the city
valava believed not only that the earth
was
flat but that the sun was only a few
thousand miles away from earth not 93
million
he also believed that the sun was only
32 miles across
not 860 000
he sounds crazy or does he
you see the same phenomenon eratosthenes
measured could be explained by a flat
earth
if the sun were only a few thousand
miles away and 32 miles across
the math would work out the same today
with the power of the internet modern
day flat earthers have picked up where
valava
left off they have quite good
explanations for any evidence you throw
at them
that the earth is round circumnavigation
is really just a flat circle path the
round shadow earth casts on the moon
during a lunar eclipse could also be
made by a flat disc
time zones are caused by a spotlight sun
and remember how gravity would be
totally different on a disc
shaped planet well they argue that
gravity as we know it simply doesn't
exist the flat disk of earth is merely
accelerating
up at 9.8 meters per second as for all
of the
photos and video evidence we now have
that the earth is round thanks to space
exploration
well all of that material is completely
fabricated
a hoax perpetrated by big globe
space agencies airlines globe
manufacturers
they are reaping the rewards of our
ignorant belief
that the earth is actually round they
know of course
that it's flat and they're hiding that
truth from us is it merely a coincidence
that the logo used by the flat earth
society
is a projection of earth centered on the
north pole and also
happens to be the projection used by the
united nations
are these people for real probably not
most of them
but this is the crux of poe's
law an adage that states that at their
extremes
parity of extremism and sincere
extremism are difficult to distinguish
although clever flat earth theories are
predominantly
ad-hoc explanations excuses made up on
the spot
that only address one issue and don't
fit all the evidence
science of course rejects a theory if a
better one fits more of our observations
but why the egotistical obsession with
our
observations a cosmic ray particle could
use the very same scientific method we
use
and conclude that the earth was in fact
flat you see at speeds near the speed of
light
time slows down and lengths contract
one way we know this is that unstable
muons created in the upper atmosphere by
the collision of cosmic rays with the
atmosphere
should mostly decay before reaching
earth's surface
but yet we detect a lot of them down
here
because their crazy fast speed literally
means that from
our perspective their physics runs
according to a slower clock
and to them the distance they have to
cover to the surface during their
short lives is from their perspective
much much shorter than it appears to us
if you were a cosmic ray proton
traveling at 99.99999999991
the speed of light earth would appear to
be only
17 meters thick in the direction you
traveled
so earth is flat to them
but round to us it is ball shaped to
some observers
and flat to others there doesn't appear
to be a single most correctist in
all circumstances answer
susan hack compares knowledge to a
crossword puzzle
new answers interweave with old ones
they all reinforce one another
the clues are the questions we ask and
the way the answers fall into a
predetermined grid
well that's our confidence that we're on
the right track but that doesn't mean
that one day there will be a finished
puzzle a complete answer recall the new
york times famous 1996 crossword puzzle
that came out
the day before the u.s election between
bill clinton
and bob dole the clue for 39 across
was pretty crazy you seem to need to be
able to tell the future to answer it
correctly
it simply said lead story in tomorrow's
newspaper elected
well that blank could be clinton or bob
dole
and who's to say which one until
tomorrow there's no way to know
but as it turned out the answer was
clinton
or bob dole no matter which you wrote in
all the other clues
fit for instance a black halloween
animal could either be
a cat or a bat our knowledge about the
outside world
might be the same a puzzle with no
answer key just the reassurance that the
answers we
think we know fit together so they're
probably
correct though there's always the
possibility that the answer to
one clue or all of them will
fundamentally
not have a single definite satisfying
answer
the puzzle may be playable forever
i like what richard feynman says about
this
some people say how can you live without
knowing
i do not know what they mean i always
live without knowing
that is easy how you get to know is what
i want to know
you know and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]